I've known her since 1996 and she is the
only member of the Oswego State
athletics Hall of Fame of ever analyzing
show she is Linda Cohen so great to be
here with you Rach I'm so saying I know
like I'm like proud mama but I'm so
proud of you look what you've built an
empire very good so yes now I mentioned
earlier yes we did Sports Center many
times way back in the day now I remember
one in particular but I mentioned
earlier yes you and I were doing like I
think like as they said the 11 o'clock
eastern show and all of a sudden we get
a phone call that we have to go on the
air immediately because a brawl has
broken out at Madison Square Garden
because the Andrew Golota riddick bowe
fight went haywire right because
normally I'm not even sure if that was
going to be our lead story of that night
at all right right or not of me that I
probably would have but yeah so when
that happens back in the day yeah we
went haywire we did I remember that we
were like you're like knocking I think
am I on the door less we gotta go down
no I had a cubicle you had an office
hello
but anyway yeah but we somehow put it
together and did a fabulous ad lived the
entire program it was one of those
thinkers you and I are both from the New
York City and we're like honestly we
were kind of I remember walking down
together or saying okay we're getting a
little bit of bits and pieces as to why
something had broken out right and we
both looked at each other like if cops
got called to Madison Square Garden all
holy heck had to have broken out and you
love boxing I mean you know give
yourself a little credit I mean you had
you totally had like done your research
on this fight I remember that with you
love the gate you know you love the
fight well you know the reason part of
the reason why I love the fight game so
much it was my way to get out of the
Sports Center studio yes Charley Steiner
he owned up doing it yeah
he stopped doing it and they asked me to
take over the piece you know this Jewish
kid from Brooklyn who's a lover not a
fighter and and I you know I remember I
remember one of the first fights I
covered Chris was the Holyfield Michael
Moore rematch in Las Vegas Nevada and I
did a piece for Sports Center Sunday
morning where you know Jack Edwards
pooped all over it you know I've told
that story and I did a story walking
around Las Vegas entertainment scene
trying to get all the sound bites of
like the Blue Man Group and a whole
bunch of other people who are on stage
at the time in Las Vegas back in that
day Donny and Marie know this is a great
story great story and I told I don't
know why I brought it up to you Linda
but I came to him like hey I got this
idea for story and all this stuff and
one of the people who said yes I will do
an interview and be part of your silly
piece was David Cassidy the first love
of my life was the greatest thing rich
has ever done he brings back a nought
you perfect an autographed picture you
said yes you said if you can get
anything can I get an autographed
picture of him and instead yes got a
photograph of you that you autographed
to him that I got him to put up in his
mirror in his dressing room credible
here's Richard Lyndon talking about the
old days at ESPN it has to be sports
related no it was something as great as
David Kent the late David Cassidy house
don't yes I know but rich that's I think
one of your top ten claims to fame for
me on my top ten my sports at our top
ten of rich aizen's greatest Cassidy
makes the top ten I'm glad I didn't make
them not tops you know what's another
one now Friday funny but not top ten yes
um but the good thing one of the shows
we did together yes I was telling lovely
Sarah in makeup yes the turn of the
century or what do they call it when we
went from
1999 to 2000 okay that's what it was
called why did I forget that Charley
Steiner again another Charlie reference
no he had a great commercial yes but we
did that amazing Sports Center it was
like visuals of all the greatest moments
of like the 90 this yeah and it was an
amine you everyone watched it I think
you can get it on YouTube and the whole
thing is they had Aerosmith dream on and
the backdrop do you remember you had
like all the greatest moments Muhammad
Ali Cal Ripken like all these iconic
sports moments why we both fell in love
with sports why we wanted to do this for
a living whose bump thing it was and
that's another show I remember with you
I do that makes our top Tim you know uh
Linda Cohen here on the rich eyes at you
who who did you who if they I know that
they did count up all your sports
centers when you passed I guess who did
you pass fine no I do I pass the 5000
milestone like two years ago and it's
still going it was Elsie 5k and so did
they count up how many you did with each
person like who do you think there's a
person you did the most sports agree
that's a great point I mean you were
definitely up there I think I mean I did
a lot we did a lot but but you know you
had you're obviously the lights to Scott
you know but we were like in that kind
of I was always that anxious you know in
the in the pen you were not in the pen
Mariano Rivera maybe I'm coming at the
millah know when I well John Franco for
you rather be Mariana remember you know
what I did more 11s with you when I
wasn't doing the two am Scott that's
true she's got a you got the earlier she
it's a great question but I would I
would think you'd be right up there and
now we've gone to the top five of sports
centers I've done the most with Rich
Eisen you have to be in the top five
well I haven't been there in 16 years
but it's possible because it's now a lot
of depth lot of what
sound like a pedo as many sports centers
Kilbourne no you're a big fan of Craig
than I was with all due respect he was
here a couple weeks sure he was is he
working anywhere he needs some help
no no rich you know what Linda you came
here he's got his you guys get his great
Instagram feed it's funny he is funny
but I always remember him all right
let's we can get off the Craig sounds it
was always nice to me yes but his focus
was being the next David Letterman and
do you remember what I always told you
hmm no and okay great I thought and I
still do just and I that's why I'm so
proud of you because I always used to
say you would make a great late-night
talk-show host
hey you're funny you can ad-lib great
you're great with people you make them
feel comfortable and now look at your
mom Linda so that's a always said that
you know Linda Cohen here on the rich
Johnson show that's me resetting with
Linda do you want a new coach for your
Giants I said this four weeks ago now
everyone's on the wagon uh you know I'm
president of the Eli Manning fan club so
I wasn't happy when that move was made I
got over it but he daniel Jones listen I
know face of the franchise you know he
has a fumbling issue no one wants to
talk about it I'm talking about it I
know he threw for four touchdowns for
the second time his career I know he
said Giants franchise records as a
rookie right he is the future he is the
present and he's a good kid these little
mini Eli but with this team it's the
defense and I'm concerned with the
defensive coordinator there's no
improvement at all in this defense they
continue to go backwards and there's no
accountability you know the Giants
culture as you know yours yeah I know
you're a jet fan but you know the giant
sculptures you know they even when
things were bad
there was someone in that locker room
that rallied the troops no one's there
in that giant locker room they say all
the right things and Pat Shermer has yet
to take responsibility at any postgame
news conference I've yet to hear him say
this is on me Doug Peterson Eagles won a
Super Bowl with Doug Peterson he takes
responsibility when his team stinks
most head coaches in the NFL as you know
take responsibility Bill Belichick takes
responsibility for the rare times the
Patriots lose right
I fit to your pet rumors say he that was
on me why would you want to hear that I
mean I do want to hear it just to hear
it I want accountability and I think it
starts with the head coach
I want accountability when my team's
lose the answer is yes you do want a
head coach your new head coach I need a
new head coach that we use of what is
seven and twenty nine and his Giants
head coaching career it's like they're
gonna have another top five pick right
now regarding just another top well as
Dave Gettleman gonna be around to make
another poor pick CIE should listen a
little respected the energon Giants
needed a pass rusher you can't win in
the NFL as you know without not only one
pass rush ent to play got kid Josh Allen
was sitting out there when they chose
Daniel Jones they just said that Daniel
Jones wouldn't have been there for the
next time around yeah maybe we on the
first no no you lived it you know you
saw it someone what you're hearing about
the way Jay Gruden has you know no
longer there they just named Wayne
Haskins the starter for the rest of the
season in Washington DC it sounds like
Washington might I hit day the daniel
Jones button and at some point you do
have to get him all these like all these
fumble that you're talking about
including Jamal Adams ripping one out of
his hands yesterday first for a
touchdown hosting a spongebob
squarepants video did you see that I
mean gosh I mean he just like he hears
the word is out around the league on
Daniel Jones right he didn't even try to
sack him he just went right for the ball
and swiped it away the leak knows about
the fumble itis problem but the way to
fix it is to get him the reps
my guess is the way to do it and if
schirmer's gonna take that those bullets
maybe he's gonna get one more year with
him and say Quan and we'll see what they
can draft look at say Quan the guys
rushed back from a high ankle sprain
you know they ruined the two best year
first two years really I mean look what
se Kwang Barclay how many
I'm concerned he's a good kid I've done
SportsCenter cruisin he's humble he's is
great so you don't know how to use him
that's why I have a problem with Shermer
they don't know how to use sake on
Barclay I know it piled up a lot of
great numbers last year but look with
the team and I felt management destroy
the aligned Manning I mean you should
have let him go and go Eli's never gonna
leave that team you should have let him
go in the offseason they'd still be 2
and 7 with him quite possibly I told you
I'm an Eli apologists but I think he
could have made a few smarter decisions
and obviously not rookie decisions hmm
and maybe would have stole a couple of
those losses now they've lost six
straight Linda Cohen here on the Rich
Eisen show who's your Super Bowl what do
you got
Patriots okay and I'll tell you they say
that you just swallowed hard no chance a
big Patriots fan I love Tom Brady okay
you know okay and then yeah but I did
swallow hard I was thinking about the
NFC and what a you know I want to see I
want to see this is what you want to see
you should see this one Jimmy Garoppolo
Jimmy G Brady playing against in his
home Bay Area San Francisco team he grew
up in love with right and then against
Jimmy G former teammate love it right
best storyline and and then your you
would like to see Jimmy G beat the
Patriots now and your son no no because
I I do love the page I don't know if the
whole culture work and I love Tom Brady
pile up the rings baby well yes because
you have to I know that possible rings
but a true diehard patriot fan yes with
this matchup would want to see Kyle
Shanahan go up 28 to 3 we Garofalo only
to lose that Super Bowl great am I wrong
Chris cuz it's gotta be a certain amount
of anger and spite in it not just you
know Brady and pages like you know what
I'm saying know exactly what you're
saying I brought this up the other day
I'm like I'm still amazing when that
when team's name their future head coach
and of course
Kyle Shannon who blew that Super Bowl
and then he's like welcomed with open
arms in San Francisco like the genius
and good for him kudos great year
amazing yes probably loose tonight but
you know the thing is uh that would be
interesting you're right but I could I I
could see it and my favorite thing in
sports is whenever any any team goes up
28 to 3 people Illinois I was I was
losing 28 to 3 and came back to win if
they came back to win on Michigan State
which was just a wonderful weekend I'm
still think Matt Ryan should have called
some kind of audible there and rose
above Kyle Shanahan's awful play :
mm-hmm
at last it did not happen not happen
alright I got a couple more minutes left
yes I will I will cede it the floor to
you on ice hockey oh yes yes daily show
on ESPN plus I know nobody cares about
the NHL and told footballs over okay
you're missing the greatness of Connor
McDavid okay alright but Teemu selänne
in studio last week all right this place
and uh okay great I'm not gonna the
penalty box actually called Salani okay
that's fine no but the NHL is great it's
very it's exciting it's an awesome it's
awesome game of the usual suspects are
fabulous okay yeah look Colorado
Avalanche look for them to be right
there I mean Sidney Crosby is still a
face a league Connor McDavid is still
the most exciting player in the league
you know what about your Rangers my
Rangers are still in a reboot it's
interesting the big talking point is
whether Henrik Lundqvist who's now like
37 years old right still got it and but
he loves being a ranger but does he want
to win a Stanley Cup more in the past it
was always love being a ranger doesn't
want to win a Stanley Cup he's like the
next Alex Ovechkin who finally won the
Cup right he's been with one franchise I
don't know a house you know I mean he's
no Tom Brady I don't think he can play
goal for four till he's 45 and hope to
win right now first first thing so
they're reboot you know it's good a lot
of good things the New York Islanders
are doing very well okay you know just
caught me up to speed
yeah going on you know let's get bit
let's get into March when there's March
Madness in the NHL and then we get into
real storylines for you in the crease on
ESPN Plus everybody with Linda Cohen
hosting hosting in the crease and of
course
when's your next SportsCenter Friday and
Saturday of this week with Kenny what
are you doing uh no idea with Stan or
Neil stand or kneel la baby
you've probably surpassed me and still
in terms of tenure at that spot yeah I'm
sure of it you know it's really the only
team left like regular team wrong about
it I mean at nighttime well van because
it's Van Pelt is just so low he's off
it's a different kind of sports son well
Scott's show is like the days when we
used to do it well yeah because listen
right Scott I love mm-hmm
he follows live events the 11:00 p.m.
Eastern used to fall live events it's a
great number and at 2:00 a.m. Eastern
used to follow the eleven o'clock you
know the Rockies versus the Dodgers
somebody's pitching into the 14th inning
and we're sitting there saying couldn't
you get this thing it's still happening
and in doing in LA and you don't sir Li
er what it's still bad the
longest-tenured anchor and SportsCenter
history Lynda Carter everybody great to
see you else it's more often since it's
a home game for you this I like that
phrase it's a home game and
congratulations on that big Jets win on
both Twitter and Instagram right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app